I want to say it's a bad dream but yeah
Kobe's gone it's not supposed to happen
to someone like Kobe you know what I
mean it's it's it's he's he's bigger
than that it's not supposed to happen to
Cove and to really wrap your head around
that it has and and that we won't get to
hear him again and we won't he won't get
to continue to spread the love and
knowledge he had it is hard what will
you miss most about them he was
touchable you know what I mean like one
of the greatest players on earth and you
didn't say hi to him and you can take
pictures with him I dismiss the father
I'm obviously tremendous one of the
greatest I don't care about that like I
miss the guy that would do anything for
my kids would do anything for his
daughters would do anything for anybody
you're a day.you coaches his kids to
write a lot like Kobe well that had to
get home he and I through odd
circumstances Boz it obviously has
teammates and brothers but through
fatherhood and and that's where we
consistently Sarge out there like every
two weeks was that you know he was
coaching GG and I was coaching my twins
explained Kobe the family man but teddy
bear you know what I mean not the not
the animal that we saw in the court in
GG when I was sitting watch her play I'm
like like what's going on here you know
her shooting fadeaways and her bite in
her jersey and her leading the team and
it gave me chills just to watch like
that is that's a little much I'm
mamacita right there they were best
afraid aren't the two peas in a pod
he spoke proudly about all this girls
including the baby girls but you know it
was a special twinkle in his eye when
you're talking Gigi and basketball code
I thought about Kobe and when he passed
and I thought losing GG also we lost
maybe a step in the evolution of women's
basketball do you think that this could
have been a revolutionary step for women
oh there's no question United mean to
have arguably one of the greatest
players of all time in the ear of a girl
who wanted it he lost a little bit of
interest in the NBA game until gg wanted
to start watching League passed and was
watching film and watching these players
and cope just really took to that I was
like okay well now it's time to get back
in the game and to know her hunger for
the game and know
the knowledge he had to give her mm-hmm
that's a I would have been a dangerous
combination when we think about those
two little girls who never really get to
know this really what do you what do you
think about them and what what do they
take from this being a father that's
that that was the hardest thing for me
knowing that Capri and Capri and Bianca
will never get to know how amazing their
father was how much he loved them how
much they were his his universe you know
I mean he told me like you seemed did
the psychotic comment he made I'm
psychotic about family time but giving
them baths taking them to school hanging
out with them reading playing with them
doing whatever it took you know I mean
that's when you saw the teddy bear like
they will never know that that teddy
bear that they're arresting was a
real-life killer on the basketball court
you know what I mean and just that's
what hurts the most is you know
obviously Vanessa but those three girls
lost an amazing man amazing father and
and in a superhero and for them not to
kind of be able to grow up and feel his
love and his passion for them it hurts
me and you look at he in Vanessa it
really says something about their love
story and how a blossom especially after
he quit playing basketball he was there
all of a sudden all this that's tough I
remember at UCLA when he was going to
her high school and picking her up in
the Lamborghinis and the helicopters
were following him and it's on the news
like this is before reality TV to think
twenty-something years later you know
what I mean and nothing is perfect you
know they went through some ups and
downs but they stuck it out and they
made it and you can never say no matter
what was going on anything bad about
Vanessa there's a lot of craziness that
goes on when people do whatever and you
still couldn't say nothing about his
Queen so he was psychotic about his
family about his daughters and just that
quality family time was the world loss
by Museum Kobe Bryant a superstar he was
bigger than life the world lost a
superstar la lost a super hero and and
his family lost one of the greatest men
ever - it's a walk to face a ptarth
you
[Music]